hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher about six years ago I taught a
student and he was diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer which is an incredibly
violent disease and he was going to miss
huge amounts of school being treated
having his immune system recover and I
knew that if we send him away for a
month just for the textbook and saying
you know have a go at chapter five in
Chapter six and you know you'll be able
to keep up while you're gone I knew that
that was going to be fatal for his
understanding of mathematics and he he
loved this subject and wanted so much to
be able to keep up with his friends and
be able to learn alongside them and just
feel like a normal kid even while who's
going through all the rigors of his
treatment regime and so I thought
technology can help with this
technology's not the point it's just a
means for addressing the needs that our
students experience and so I pulled the
phone out of my pocket and I thought
this will take decent video of my
whiteboard it won't be amazing but
you'll be able to see what's happening
you can hear what I'm explaining and so
often I mean when I was at school if you
had sat me down with a mathematics tech
guru and said you know just read these
lines and then hopefully you'll
understand I would have had no clue
because I was always that kid who said
wait how did they get from this line to
that line like always the connection I
don't understand what I needed and what
I think so many of us need is someone to
guide me through to put those pieces
together and explain what all the links
are so it makes sense in my mind and
that's what I wanted to give this
student through giving him my videos of
my classrooms lessons just as my other
students were experiencing it I put it
on YouTube because that seemed like the
most straightforward simple way to do it
and unknowingly in doing that I opened
up my classroom to the world and sort of
you know opened up the opportunity for
people to learn from the lessons that I
was giving which I didn't think anyone
would be interested in but it clearly
scratched a niche that's there and it's
been amazing to me to see those videos
go around the country even around the
world to touch on the fact that
mathematics is a universal language and
despite the fact that many people
dislike this subject I think the reason
they just like it is because they don't
understand
and once they do and all the pieces
click into place it's an immensely
satisfying subject to learn and through
doing that I mean gaining attention and
exposure in a variety of ways that I
never would have predicted it's been
incredible that this year in the
Australian of the Year awards I was
named Australia's local hero which is
still a shock to hear and to say even
coming out of my own mouth but that's
given me the wonderful opportunity to
travel all around Australia to see and
be inspired by the great work that's
happening in schools all around the
country and also to support and
encourage that myself and to help people
see mathematics in a different way
that's a bit of the journey that I've
been on and I'm just so delighted and
privileged to be able to have that
impact on people around the country
[Music]